hey guys I'm Ryan Wright and I'm Arianna
ba Suri so Arianna old friend of mine he
used to hang out a lot
now she is over at our place and I
thought which is she a [ __ ] video
everyone's asking me to check out this
video it's one of my favorite artists of
all time The Slim Shady
the Marshall Mathers the M and M rap God
performed in 40 styles ten second songs
no idea what this is I love the song rap
God okay 40 different styles by ten
second songs hurt your feelings but it's
been way too again the last 20 stars
soft so how about I give you 40 styles
this time some of you telegin to it and
if I proved wrong or in big trough why
don't we take it from the first lips I'm
a rapper mutants be my genes i got a
laptop in my backpack
mom let me go off it up
yeah actually
Oh
impressive
Wow
get up so you look at it straight
looking boy
people that the bad guy
this is so impressive
sighs clinics quick table no ask
yeah
it's coming up right now you only get to
confuse guys voters to you so let me
know when it occurs warmer than any one
of these verses verses in curtain two
min barely earn you I mean if it's got
Murder two approved if you have a spicy
songs you sacrifice person to uh it's
cool funky pills work of Italy AK elite
skill Romney hole myself is so hungry
have almost ended up in momentum and I'm
a million leagues love you
this can't all be away
don't mistake him to stay in its fatal
mistake you think I need to be overseas
and take a vacation to trip abroad and
make a bill on the face in your [ __ ]
be a king thingg nah but be a king when
you can be that again what's going on
everybody thanks for watching if you
like what you see check out the other
videos on my page and subscribe to my
channel if you haven't already look damn
whoa holy [ __ ]
that was one of the most impressive
things I've ever seen I can't even do
the fast part completely he did like so
much Oh money the switches to a genetic
tongue I know I know I'm trying right I
had Alice e Oh me out right now that's
all it takes that's the only thing
missing yeah very happy
yeah is my vision I don't have I need a
vagina okay yeah that was that was
really impressive um III don't
I've never seen this before it sounds
like this is a pretty popular chance
I've seen his work before okay I've
never seen this what a brilliant YouTube
channel idea that is brilliant so great
you think he was in LA Anthony Vincent
yeah Anthony Vincent Wow
Anthony's my brother's named Miles
attractive him anymore well I don't know
your brother do I know you really I I
don't care that was very impressive
though okay seriously already on us
something has to be done about your
boobs they are so huge on camera I'm not
even I'm not coming on to you it's raw
I'm not hitting on you this I just took
my shirt off look in the camera I was
like holy [ __ ] that's like taking up
half of the screen right now
congratulations
now they don't even look that yeah okay
if you're new to the channel you can
subscribe to the real rejects Ariana's
gonna be starting up a channel soon
alright people look out for that and you
can follow us on Facebook Instagram and
Twitter
where Ariana's constantly posting
pictures of her in her boobs
well I don't know if that's how I yeah I
show enough of my boobs you show plenty
of your boobs I don't know that I have a
girlfriend I'm in love with her
right baby I mean you've done me since I
was like none
you were always some know me when I was
like 10 years old yeah even then no
that's no yeah no yeah I was like a flat
skinny little Jew
you were flat skinny Jew with a [ __ ]
I think it is so awfully it tires going
on here tires I don't know why use tires
that is not a good dispersion the baby
smell like sweater puppies just super
sexy